whoa hello I'm Greg Alba what hello I'm
Brianna white Brianna Wharton I are
gonna watch the trailer for fantastic
beasts and where to find them official
teaser trailer number one I watched the
first trailer with you yes didn't tell
us anything about it and that was just a
teaser yeah this is also a teaser pretty
minutes long that's longer than a normal
teaser much we'll call some official
trailer yeah okay let's do it I'm
already
you're interesting man mr. Scamander
just like your suitcase I think there's
much more to you than meets the eye
and get out of huggers
danger your life the beasts
at one of your teachers arguing strongly
against your expulsion
what makes Albus Dumbledore so fond of
you mr. Scamander first trip to America
yes must get that fixed anything edible
in there I'm a nut knife any livestock
welcome to New York
Oh God
I'm using
Wow
no human could do with this thing is
capable of feral yeah yeah this one
right yeah
Sooey
I have full-body chills mommy - my
nipple chills are through the roof right
now
Hotel not is it really feel the nipple
feels leg chills you don't have nipple
chills right now my god no I mean like I
love Harry Potter belly not that much
well it's just habit I get excited you
know
believer series what just happens okay
this is a much more in-depth trailer
yeah which I am so pleased about it
hinted a little bit to the political
climate which I know not everybody reads
Harry Potter for that but like the true
fans please really she that I'm every
Potter is it it's just that the world is
so dense and then there's so much to not
only dive into but also there's room for
imagination - I think JK Rowling is a
really really amazing job of that and
this looks like this is gonna be amazing
follow-up you actually read the books
right yes like fantastic piece I haven't
read that one but I have the actual like
I gave it the book yeah what is it
so the movie is based off the book which
is a textbook called fantastic beasts
and where to find them but the movie is
the main character writing that textbook
okay
Oh story of how the textbook was created
so I yeah but these are even actually a
book in and of it okay what I'm really
excited for it is like as I think the
Harry Potter movies I've only heard the
first three books I got immediately lazy
after that I was like I've accomplished
a lot you know the third one is the best
so does it fight me on it is it it is
the best it kind of didn't get me
excited the third one is the best book
house what about movies
oh the movies is hard they're all good
yeah but everyone is really good because
it's based on the best book but I
personally like the tone of the later
films
yeah me too a little bit more epic you
know I feel like with this it's gonna be
something that is truly different
there's gonna be the Harry Potter world
nostalgia yeah however it still feels
like oh we are exploring some winter fun
mastic music came in yeah like take me
now Harry Potter you know like when they
had Daniel Radcliffe cast as Harry
Potter yeah we didn't know who Daniel
Radcliffe was right everyone knows that
this guy is a good hacker yeah he's
really [ __ ] good yeah it's exciting
to see that the lead is someone we
actually already familiar with and know
it's true that's true it could be a good
thing could be a bad thing because now
he won't really truly belong in the
Harry Potter world because we know him
from elsewhere but he's a good enough
actor to where I feel like he can do it
I mean just because we know him in the
Harry Potter world yeah he can be part
of the Harry Potter world well it's like
anytime you see like Angelina Jolie in a
movie or like Jennifer Aniston movie
just for example you're watching
Angelina Jolie or Jennifer Aniston but
when you watch Jana Rock Live it's Harry
Potter you're like that's Harry Potter
he is no one else cuz he's not a
celebrity outside of the movie I get
what you're saying
no I feel like though he can really
transform I feel like he's a good enough
actor to where I do have hope yeah I
think he can do it he's a transformation
not seeing become a woman
I saw him become Stephen Hawking he was
amazing yeah he was amazing in that I
know yeah no he's great the fact that
they took the sequel they turned the
theory of everything and it made the
sequel to Danish for all that Stephen
Hawking's becoming the first woman
amazing
it's a weird headcanon she knows the
character back yes I'm really excited
about this movie fantastic beasts and
where to find them
yeah the effects look great you know in
the trailer when they said like a new
era yeah I love how they made that very
clear for me yeah because it is like
hopping into a new era it's it's this
it's the world of Harry Potter but it's
a new era so it looks different you know
exactly and I also like that they have
it set in America
instead of setting in Britain yeah I
feel like I feel like that's good I feel
like we needed it's a little bit of a
brand it's important it's important
murka and they should have cast an
American actor to play the lead
well-known British accent okay so that
moment where they were like he went to
Hogwarts but he didn't get expelled
because Albus Dumbledore vouched for him
I was like you know he's alive again
okay in any way this would eventually
link up to Harry Potter well there are
gonna be little times like that like
references to Albus Dumbledore as a
younger person but I'm saying we can
make like it and and see you have a
cinematic universe out of the Harry
Potter
each PC you sounds like a printing
program it does what amazing windows
yeah I think this is gonna be really
amazing because Harry Potter world in
Universal also just opened up have you
been like I'm going to what next next
next week Wow yes so it opened last week
I think okay so it's gonna be opening
soon and I'm really excited not only to
see how it compares to Universal Orlando
which I've been to but also how they tie
in fantastic beasts and where to find
them
could be pretty cool damn good marketing
yeah it's like a plan mr. Sun right they
thought years ahead on this map I'm
really excited
all right guys fantastic beasts and
where to find them thank you for saying
that I should watch this trailer I think
I brought the perfect guest on for this
video just a little bit of a fan it's
little bit nice people I made that sign
for me for other okay yeah it's
unfortunate listen guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe today
become a reject buzz zing go to Breanna
White's channel sibling rivalry if you
like watching pretty girls play awesome
video games well you're in for a treat
because that's essentially what the
channel consists of yeah pretty much
watch Anna would you ever cook call
yourself out loud a pretty person oh no
good I don't ever do that yeah it's like
so against the rules
oh so against the way yeah I've round up
on that too just makes you look bad
when I'm a handsome devil it's not a
double standard at all the hell is that
double standard doesn't it make sense